I have never seen anything like what
families have gone through now I don't
know how they're going to cope I don't
know how they're going to react when
there's no food in the fridge I don't
know what they're going to do when the
children doesn't have breakfast going to
school
we can very very much say that because
the living process has hit different
parts of the country very very unequally
inflation has predominantly affected
things which people with lower income
spend more on today's things like energy
and food The increased price of basic
products have made life very difficult
for the lower income bracket or the
lowest 20 to 40 percent of earners
Nationwide
he is a single dad of three and lives in
housing provided by the borough of
Chelsea and Kensington he relies
entirely on universal credit for his
income which is paid out monthly and
provided by the government for
individuals who are out of work or
living on a low income
I'm looking for part-time work because I
take my two youngest into Primary School
the earliest I could start if I have a
job in that area is 9 30 and then I have
to finish at 2 30 to collect them at 3
10. so that is the problem in fact I
haven't come across any jobs yet that
are just those tight hours I don't have
any family so I have no one to help me
and the temporary what I'm applying for
is mostly close to minimum wage Which is
less than most the child care in this
Borough for around a fifth of parents in
the UK child care costs account for more
than half of their household income
the UK is now one of the most expensive
countries for child care in the oecd so
for those without a decent income there
is no chance to pay for child care to be
able to go and work so the Universal
Credit because I have three children I
get tops up so it's just over a thousand
a month which sounds quite a lot but
it soon goes because I have the gas and
electricity the gas particularly when
it's cold is costing a lot now what I do
is I turn the gas on and off in December
with gas and electricity prices through
the roof over 7 million were going
without Basics like food and Heat
at 4.7 million were behind on their
bills food is a good crazily expensive
for instance the other day we hadn't had
ketchup for about a month that children
said come on let's have ketchup again
it's nice for the chips the cheapest
ketchup I could get was 450.
this is where Dad's house is really
helped I gave to lunch there once a week
but also they have a food bank that
makes all the difference and Billy he
was a single dad himself he set out this
charity 15 years ago he really helps me
because he knows I've got three kids I
haven't got any other help
you say it's a food bank it's not just
for single dads it's for anyone in the
community
so that's probably saving me 600 pounds
a month so that enables me to stay
solvent but without that well our diet
would suffer we've got roughly between
60 and 70 000 families registered we've
got between 40 and 50 families a day
coming to your dad's house the demand
for the work that we do and went through
the roof especially due to the cost of
living and it's absolutely heartbreaking
when you see our mum or dad who is
absolutely struggling when it comes to
not being able to cook for the children
almost 90 percent of independent food
banks say they saw an increase in demand
compared to last year and over 80
percent reported supporting a
significant number of people needing
help for the first time we can't plan
it's impossible because
we do not get the financial donations
that we did get and
every day is really difficult to
maintain that level sometimes we have
had to go into other reserves to use
that to buy food and to provide small
glands we struggle and it's
heartbreaking when but you can't give to
anyone
[Music]
you know so we'll go to the shops and
we'll buy food and we'll go to the bank
and take money from the account so we
can give that Dad
a little bit of cash that you can go and
buy food
um it can put 50 pounds in the electric
when we can it's I can't sleep at night
1254.
for everything for a month a dick off at
least that 254 for travel I've got
direct debits
um which is 200 so you're left with 200
a week okay
so take off 50 pounds a week for gas and
electricity so if you buy no clothes no
toiletry no medical stuff no emergencies
no luxuries no birthday presents you're
left with 150 pounds for food and if you
don't have access to a food bank
that has got to last as I said before if
it wasn't for the help I received from
Dad's house it would be extremely
difficult and their diet would be
affected and Peter had said that he
Universal Credit increased around 10 in
Spring to help with inflation though
this provided some relief the food
insecurity of the past year is why UK's
leading Charities such as the Trussel
trust are petitioning for an Essentials
guarantee a way to avoid the increased
poverty and help with basic needs that
benefits couldn't cover for so many
months they see the cost of living
crisis has exposed the erosion of UK's
benefits system so I think what I'm
hearing when I'm speaking to people is
that there is support out there but it
could be utilized a lot better when you
talk to food banks people are really
really worried I have asked people
repeatedly like when do you think it's
going to get better and there's just
this Bleak silence there's this kind of
question mark I'm incredibly grateful
for and appreciative
of what you do get help with in this
country what kind of helps keep you
going
my children
[Music]
foreign